hey how are you hi great how are you
today
i'm good okay i'm gonna try not to geek
out but i'm talking to one of
the most iconic girl groups of all time
um
i wanna ask how difficult was it keeping
it a secret that you're gonna be a part
of this sequel
it's very difficult because we're so
proud of this movie and
you know you want to have something to
to back to brag about a little bit
like and we have not been able to say
anything
all this time so you know there's going
to be some family members going
right so
what was it like getting that phone call
to you know ask to be a part of this
film
it was surreal um because like cindy
said i mean the film is so
iconic and uh you know was first aired
in 1988 and so this many years later
to have gotten a call to participate in
this film the sequel
and work with salt and peppa is just
like a dream come true
okay so you have to tell me what was it
like on set like was it everything that
you hoped it would be
and more and more i don't know if rona
do you want to take that question or i
can
yeah we had a great time i mean we we
really enjoyed uh the wardrobe
you know putting that together that was
so much fun the colors the set
um everybody that was there had really
good energy
uh sherry headley was there john amos
was there um
people were just i think it was just
kind of buzzing with that
this is this is happening you know
coming to america
classic film so we're so excited to be a
part of it it was great
well it seems how obviously you guys are
fans of the original the original is
such an iconic film it's like a perfect
film for so many people
so of course there's a lot of
expectations when it comes to a sequel
so
what do you guys know as fans of the
original love about this one
i personally like um the storyline
i was pleasantly surprised how they were
able to flip that
they brought in a lot of iconic talent
uh to the set to bring this story to
life so that was special to watch um
something that
you didn't see as much of but in this
film you're getting
all kinds of amazing uh talented stars
that have contributed
their efforts to this um but i think the
story line might surprisingly be pretty
good considering it's a sequel and we're
gonna love it anyway i think just
because it's a classic right
but the storyline is actually pretty
good
cindy and terry how did you react when
you saw the film
oh it was it was amazing um because um
you know to see all of the iconic um
stars that are in it
and as rona said it's a really good
storyline
and um and then every all of the cast
members from the
the first movie are in this movie
so they didn't leave a single person out
unless there's someone that's no longer
here with us on the planet but
all of the stars that was really
exciting and more and all the stars
and more it's a star-studded film on top
of all of that
um and it was exciting to see eddie
murphy back into all those different
characters that he did in the first
movie
and he and just as he did it all just
as perfectly as he did in the first film
and arsenio hall too
um and so it was just really exciting to
see all of that and go oh yeah
you know she's bad yeah it was sick it
was really great
and then just visually in so many ways
it's stunning yes
visually stunning they really they
pulled out all the stops on wardrobe
on set design um it's just
really uh a beautiful thing to behold
yeah i think fans are gonna lose it like
i think you're just gonna love it
i really really do um you know it's wild
to think that you celebrated your 30th
anniversary last year from
your first album uh you know when you
think of all your time spent together
and everything you've been through
how would you describe your friendship
right now
like fine wine
like fine wine you know i think um
we've gone through trials and
tribulations and
you know we've grown we've evolved and i
think we've become better people
um and i think even more passionate
about our career
um i'm gonna say um more respectful
um you know uh
to each other and for what we do and
and the work that we put into this you
know the the time the effort
um yeah
that's what you good answer well i have
to tell you it was just such a pleasure
uh seeing this film getting to interview
you guys has just made my day
so thank you so much i really really
appreciate it
thank you
you